Going back to the topic of beds and everything opinions on pajamas.
Do any of you guys wear pajamas? Like specifically, like pajamas? Yeah.
Just pajamas. No, for me, it's just like underwear and some random are good.
I don't understand pajamas at all. Um, yeah.
Some people do wear a t-shirt to bed. I don't want to wear it.
Why would you wear it today? I mean, it's like stinking hot, like in the summer,
like I'll, I'll wear no shirt,
but most of the time max comfort is the least amount of clothes you could wear
basically. And like, you know, you basically only wear boxes, so you're,
you're dangly bits. Don't go everywhere. Yeah.
That's pretty much the only way freedom though, you know, let them loose.
I'm sleeping. I want to be comfy. No, I'm like, I dunno.
I like wearing a t-shirt because sometimes in the morning the weather can like
completely change. So I don't, especially nowadays in the winter,
like I'm a little bit too cold if I don't wear at least a t-shirt even with the,
even with the heater on. Yeah. But yeah. I don't know.
When you say you're like a friend's house, right? What do you do?
Do you wear a t-shirt when you sleep? Cause I'm just like immediately. I'm like,
right. I'm stripping all day. It depends how close I am to that friend. Right?
I mean, it doesn't matter who it, who they are. I'm like right.
If I'm staying in your house, I'm sorry. I'm asleep. Like,
I'll see with boxes on I'll humor. You, I won't get my junk everywhere.
I'll super boxes on my bike. You can just not wear a shirt.
I can't sleep with the t-shirt. Why? Why did I feel like I'm outside still?
You know what? I take the tissue off in my head at signifies, like, okay,
we're going to bed or I'm going in the bath.
Are you the type of person who like, when doing like a serious, like heavy,
like you have to like take your shirt off. No, but wait, wait. No,
I know. Yeah. Go, go, go, go, go. No,
if like, I, I had a few friends where like,
like if the pain was like really, like, it was such a powerful.
It'd be like to like fully get out like a hundred percent of that.
[inaudible] [inaudible] man.
I need to take my shirt off to get serious.
[inaudible] in camera. No way is serious Goku with
[inaudible] or something. It's like, hold on.
Let me use a hundred percent of my power to push this because you're like
sweating so hard. You're just like, I need to take my shirt off. Okay. Also,
when, when you're, when you're like hungry,
when you're hung over the shifts, the shifts are terrible though.
So you're like. I mean, I just woke up I'm naked. So it. I'll do it.
When I'm naked, I'm going to lie.
I've had moments where been so like powerful and stressful. I'm just like,
I have to take my shirt off.
I don't do that, but I know people live here. Not enough. It's like placebo,
but like it works. He's
Tyler on us. On the show. Yeah.
The only time I, when I'm like, if I'm ever like vomiting,
I want to be naked because I want to get that anywhere or smell my clothes.
So I'm like, I'll just do it. And I'll hug this toilet bowl until I'm done.
You're hugging it. Then there's no way you're going to like onto your.
That in my clothes, my clothes at all, man. I'm like, I don't know. I just,
I also feels better. I dunno. Why feel it? Like I need to get,
I didn't get like, it's too strict. I'm getting stuffing in these.
I just want to vomit. Like, I don't know, like when I was to have like,
did you follow me with that?
Because every time I've seen you bumping you have closed. Oh yeah, sure.
And I'm like, you know, if you have like, if you're really sick,
you're like when I had food poisoning back at like, whenever I, you know,
when they thought I had the Brona, like I was like vomiting. And like,
I had to be like naked because I was like,
otherwise I feel like get on my clothes. And I'm like, that's gross.
It's so fun. Little. Did you know that during the chess tournament,
every time you went to jail, he just rip off his suit. That was awful.
That with the suit on I'm like, please don't get it on the suit.
That's the worst timing to take a. It's winter enough slurry.
[inaudible] it was gross. No.
Cause like for me wearing a t-shirt in bed is just like sometimes,
especially in the winter. Yeah. You wake up and it's like a cold morning.
I love that. And like, how do you escape your DV at that point? Yeah.
You just it's it's like, I don't know, being branded. You'd like just do it.
Do it for me. It's just like, gravity has increased tenfold.
I'm like experiencing 10 GS in this bed right now. It's like,
I actually can't get on. Literally takes me like an hour to get out of bed.
I have like the call of duty, like text, pop it up on my screen mission,
get to the shallow. Like that's what it's like for me, one limb at a time to be,
let me, let me just get my right arm out. And once that's like room temperature,
then I'll get my right leg out. It's like, all right now.
But I used to have like a heated thing that you could put into your bed. Right.
But that just made me lazy. So I got rid of it. What do you mean?
I never wanted to lie bad, like a heated thing under the mattress.
He was like just always warm. But then I was like, this is also a fire hazard.
Uh, and uh, yeah, I just don't. I can not get out of bed with this thing. Yeah,
that's true.